sie sind politiker im bayerischen
landtag aber sie konnten jetzt eben
nicht still sitzen in dieser krise ist
nicht dabei bewenden lassen dass die
politiker sind sondern sie wollten mit
anpacken was genau haben sie gemacht
ich bin für vier wochen im rahmen
unserer parlamentsferien erste 3d
landtag hatte parlamentspause hierzu
über weihnachten vier wochen bin ich
zurück in meinen alten beruf gegangen
und hab auch ne kovic intensivstation
dort meine erfahrung als
fachkrankenpfleger für intensiv und
anästhesie haben versuchte einzubringen
und war das so eine blöde politiker
pr-aktion oder haben sich die kollegen
da wirklich gefreut rüber und sie können
wirklich etwas bewirken
gabi am anfang muss ich ihnen
ehrlicherweise nicht ebenfalls gedacht
oh gott oh gott jetzt kommt ein
politiker aber die haben relativ schnell
festgestellt ok haben er packt jetzt
wirklich mit an der iss dich nach zwei
stunden und dann pressefoto wieder weg
relativ schnell eigenständige patienten
verantwortung übernommen war nach einer
woche komplett mitglied in diesem
großartigen tiefen und vollkommen als
kollege akzeptiert ich hab manchmal auch
gerade auch in der politik gerade in der
krise eine gewisse wie sie sagen
anpacker mentalität möchte aber gerade
meine politiker kolleginnen aufregend
ein bisschen in schutz nehmen
weil wenn ich anpacken dann muss ich ja
auch in alle konsequenzen mit allen
konsequenzen klar kommen und alle
verantwortung übernehmen und das macht
aktuell aufgrund einer ja zum teil sehr
hitzigen beziehungsweise zum teil ja
wirklich von hass geprägten debatte in
den sozialen medien im internet relativ
schwierig dass man da konkret auf ihr
endlos langen bekennt und dann wirklich
dafür auch verantwortung übernimmt